無知と感情は問題です
それで物事を変化させても
問題っていうのは我々の無知と感情なんですね
危険なのは自然の変化ではなく
心の無知と感情なのです
世の中で危険なのは自然の変化じゃないんです
心にある無知と感情なんです
それでなければ臨界事件は起きません
心に問題がある 大量破壊兵器で困っているとか
人種差別で困っているとか
あり得ません 自然の流れでは
自然の流れでせいぜいまあもうアフリカとかそこら辺でもうエチオピアとか
この乾季になったとか
1年も 2年も雨が降らなかったとか
そんな程度ですよ だから問題は心の無知と感情なんです
で これ少悪多苦と読むんですけどね
一切の罪を犯さないこと
善を行うこと 心を清らかにすることが初仏の教えです
だからブッダたちは心を清らかにしなさいと一言葉で
新刊作ってくださいじゃないんです
だからお釈迦様 なんかどこかに中国の人がね
馬鹿なことを誰にもそんなこと言える言えるんだと
ブッダの罪を犯さないこととかね
そんなもの そんな理解ブッダ言ったのはと
なんか中国で馬鹿にされたというエピソードがあります
そんな程度なんですけど
しかし これがブッダの言葉なんです
新刊の罪も作ったんだからといって
原発を造って電気作ってるんだからって何もなってないんです
手を加えることで危険だけです
なぜ危険かというと 心がダメだからなんです
でなきゃ危険じゃないんです
だから手を加えるべきなのは心を清らかにすることなんです
これが絶対的にやるべきことであって
だからブッダたるものはそれを言うんです
しかし 人は物質ばかり変えようと無駄な努力をしているんです
しかし 聞いてくれません
そんなのは子供に言えるものでしょうとかね
偉そうなこと言って 私はもう彫刻作りますよと
私は絵画作りますよと
物質を作ろうと思ってるんです
無知な心で 汚れた心で物事を変えてはならないんです
ですから 科学発展する権利はないんです
心が汚れてるんです 金儲けたい気分で薬なんか作ってはいけないんです
やってますでしょうに
だから世の中は発展か後退かわからなくなっているんです
俗世間の生き方こそが危険です
苦しみを延々と試す行為です
俗世間何をやっているのかと苦しみを延々と試そうと考えています
では 限度がないものあるんですかね
あります 何にも限度があるのに
心の欲望 願望 期待などは無料です
限度がないものあります
心の期待 願望 欲望 しかし
私は気をつけて限度という言葉を使っていないんです
あの無料ということで
無料と限度はまた違います
心は汚れてないならば
無料の願望で構わないんですよ
綺麗な心だったら立派でしょう
無料の願望があって全部立派です
しかし 心は限度まで極限に汚れているんです
これ以上は汚れないというもの
だから全ての希望は危険です
だから怒りに狂った人の希望って何ですかね
欲に溺れてる人の夢希望って何ですかね
いい希望ないでしょう
したがって一切の欲望
願望は危険です だから仏教では欲望
願望は良くないんだと
良くないんだから良くないと言うんです
心は限度まで汚れているんです
破壊へ苦しみへ進むが
幸福や成長へと進まないんです
人類は なぜ人類は破壊へ進むのかというと
そういうわけ 幸福へ進まないんです
できるだけ早く飛ばさないと
欲望が現れる原因 では
もうちょこっとポイントを変えます
なんで欲望が現れるんですかね？欲望はいらんいらん
あかんあかんと言ってもあるでしょ
欲望希望を捨てなさいと言うと
どんな危険なこと そんな暗い話と思っちゃうんです
希望があった方が明るいんじゃないかと思っちゃいますけど
生きるとは 眼耳鼻舌身意で色声香味触法という情報に触れて認識が進むことです
科学的に生きるということはこういうことなんです
眼耳鼻舌身意があって
そちらの色声香味触法という情報に触れるんです
触れると認識するんです
それに生きるということを言うんです
情報に触れると感覚が生まれるんです
感じちゃうんですね 触れた情報は生命に苦楽
不苦不楽の感覚になるんです
情報が振ると苦になるか
楽になるか 不苦不楽になるかなんです
これが生きることなんです
ただ情報に触れるだけ
３つの感覚に対して執着が現れるんです
感覚に執着するんです
感覚に執着が現れるんです
人間が馬鹿だから物に執着するんです
この花が欲しいと思っちゃうんです
欲しい気持ちを作ったのは自分の感覚なんです
なぜなら 別な人はその花が欲しいと思わないんです
楽な感覚生まれた人だけそれに執着するんです
だから花に何か問題あるわけじゃないんです
自分に問題あるんだけど
それを気にしません しかし
物事は無常で変わるでしょ
この花が欲しいなと思ったっても
花が無常だから変わるんです
物事は不完全です うん
変わるっていうことは不完全ということですね
だから変わっちゃいます
したがって 現れる感覚は物足らないんです
不完全なものから喜びを感じるんだから
喜びも物足らないんです
楽を作っても 受楽というか
あまり単語の意味は調べてても出てこなかったんです
できる前に変わっていくんです
受ける功楽 なんとかなんとか漢字があります
いわゆる花を見て楽しいんですよ
十分楽しむ前に花が散ってしまうんです
ご飯を食べると美味しいんですよ
しかし 体が十分味を感じる前にお腹がいっぱいになってもう食べられなくなっちゃう
ご飯が消えるんです だから物足りないんです
これは無常だからやね
享受する前 享受って え？享受
うん うん 感じるっていうこと
そういうこと  十分に感じる
享受できる前に変わっていくんです
そうなってくると やっぱり欲しくなるでしょ
食べようと口に運んだソフトクリームは
舌に触れる瞬間で地面に落ちたような気分です
人間が だからずっと渇愛があるんです
当然渇愛が生まれるんです
それで欲望や希望や夢想や妄想や激流するんです
これはもう自然法則 大変なことです
どうにもならん ものは無常だから
こちら享受する前に消えちゃうんですね
これが もっと食べたかったのに
もっと楽しみかったのに
もう消えちゃう それでも渇愛が生まれるんです
だから渇愛ない生命はいませんよ
いっぺんこれ正しいかどうか分かりませんけど
いっぺんに大量の欲望が起こりませんが
生きている瞬間瞬間 欲望や不満感が生じることは避けられない
本当はある瞬間で大量に欲望あるわけじゃないんです
そんな心には 心の要求はそんな大きくないんです
しかし どんな瞬間でも欲望があるんです
例えば ある瞬間で世界制覇したいと
ごちそうも食べたいと
踊りも見たいと思わないんです
ある瞬間で何かやりたいと思うだけで
次の瞬間に別なことをやりたいと思うだけで
思い出してみたら やりたいことは無限にあるだけ
やっぱり瞬間では一つだけなんで
やりたがるのは 無明がない生命
渇愛がない生命 欲望願望がない生命は成り立たないんです
かなり間違ってます 成り立たないんです
無明がない生命はいません
渇愛がない生命はいません
欲望がない生命はいません
だって無常の中で生きているんだから
これもまた因果法則です
それもまた因果法則です
嫌だと思ったからといって消えるものではありません
だから私は渇愛があって
嫌だ この渇愛はと思ったって意味がないんです
因果法則ですからね 嫌だと思っても
あるものはあるんです
怒りたくないんだと言ったっても起こるんです
これは別なプロセスで解決しないと
で 命の限度 あれテーマ終わったんで
そのテーマです 体を持って生まれるでしょ
何をどの程度で認識できるのかは
肉体のリミットで定めてしまうんです
体を持った時点で 知る世界はにリミットがかかるんです
肉体持ったらもうそれで認識にリミットがかかるんです
飼い主と付き合っているが
犬には会話ができませんでしょ
飼い主というのはずっと一緒に生活しているでしょ
仲良く 犬も仲良くしたいんです
しかし 会話できません
リミットがかかってます
塩と醤油をたっぷりかけた焼き魚は人間には美味しいが
ウサギには食べ物ではありません
ウサギの体を持ったらそこでリミットができちゃって
人間の体を持ったらリミットができちゃう
だからウサギ食べるものは人間に美味しくないし
人間食べるものはウサギに美味しくないんです
次の命の限度 今説明したのは肉体の限度
これから業の限度があります
肉体と厳しい制限の中で生きているのです
生命は この肉体は業というエネルギーが作ったものです
肉体を作ったのは業なんです
現に接近いで どの程度でどれぐらいの量の刺激を受けられますか？という使用制限
これまた間違ってますね
賞味期限 賞味期限  接近とか
接近じゃない  あ は要りません
だから体持っちゃうと体作るのは業ですよ
業がどの程度で楽しめるかと決めます
賞味期限も肉体のね 業で決めてます
保証期間もね 何年間保証するのかと
全部業が決まってます
こちらで頑張っても 120年生きてやるぞとかね
業がちゃんと保証期間があります
業にそれは超えられません
さかのぼって変えることは不可能です
だから変えたければ また過去に戻って
生まれる以前 別な気持ちでまた生まれ変わらなければ不可能でしょうに
もう一度自分に遡って
赤ちゃんになって またお腹に戻って
また過去世に行って また死ぬ時
別な業で ありえないんです
一旦鶏は卵を産んだら産んだで
これ元に戻せません だから一旦生まれたら
賞味期限も保証期間も全部カチッと決めちゃうんです
それは命の制限です というわけで楽しめる限度
人は一生目を介して楽しめる量
舌を介して楽しめる量などに限度があるんです
ですから 各人に目を介して楽しめる量
耳を介して楽しめる それぞれの人によってあります
限度が 業の結果なので
一人一人が違います だから耳の力
目の力 舌の力 全部一人一人違います
寿命が作る前にまたあの感じですけどね
工事の回数券が終わったら
人生は手に負えない 暴走して破壊になるんです
だからこの回数券 早く終わっちゃいけませんよ
目でどれぐらい見えるかと回数券があります
そこは 30代で終わったならば
残り 40年どうしますかね
耳で聞こえる回数券があります
賞味期限 保証期間 これはみるみるうちに使ってしまえば
それからどうしますかと
それで暴走するんです
また手に負えないんです
本人も何するかわからなくなっちゃう
自殺するわ いろんなことをする
とにかくそれから破壊します
はい 寿命を全うすることはできなくなるんです
寿命を全うしたければ
丁寧に回数券を使わなくちゃいけないんです
楽しんではあかんという意味は仏教でないんです
楽しむために自分の過去の業の回数券 1枚
1枚  1枚あげなくちゃいけないんです
それは新しく買うことできません
一個一個の人生には生まれるとセットがあるんです
業を背負って生まれるというんだからね
で 賞味期限 眼耳鼻舌身の仕様を使用してもしなくても
寿命とともに衰えていくんです
それで眼耳鼻舌身に賞味期限もあります
だから目を使おうか 使わないで我慢しようとか関係なく
賞味期限の時は消えます
缶詰に賞味期限がある場合は
缶詰を開けておこうか
そのまま開けないで置いておこうか
賞味期限になったらもう膨らんでいます
もう使えないんです 若い時苦労したからといって
老後は贅沢できませんよ
若い時苦労したんだから
思い存分老後贅沢するぞと
無理 もう賞味期限切れてます
昔やりたかったことはこれからもやらない方が安全です
みんなそれやりますね
昔これやりたかったと
昔やりたかったことは
昔できなかったならば
これからもやらない方がいいんです
エントロピーはどうにもならないんですよ
これはエントロピーということね
まあかなり時間が経ちましたから
ちょこっと休みます ポイントの真ん中ですけど
ちょっと 休憩いたします
えーと まあスピードをちょっと上げます
まあ今終わったポイントは
まあ我々はね まあもうなんて言いますか
ケチって美味しいものも食べないで
もう我慢しても 年取ってからはもうできないんですよ
結局は体に賞味期限がありますから
もうどうにもならん それから次に勉強してほしいのは
この調和ということなんです
これ大事なポイントです
体を使いすぎ 耳を使いすぎ
舌を使いすぎ 人などはいますね
世の中で 結構います 音楽家なんかは耳の使いすぎ
使いすぎの部品は限度を超えると壊れますね
目であろうが 耳であろうが
鼻であろうか お腹であろうか
体のある部品を使いすぎになると
その部品の賞味期限ではなくて
保証期間が切れちゃって
もう使えなくなるんです
しかし 体のあまり使っていない部品は健康でいることはありません
だから 例えば目だけ使いすぎ
しかし 耳がすごく使ってないんだからね
すごく機能しているんだと
舌が使ったことないんだから
すごく機能しているんだということはありえないんです
これがすごい大変なところなんですよ
例えば 足は使わなかった人がいるとしましょう
体の他の部品は使ってます
そこで手やら他の部品は使って使って
もうもう壊れちゃった
じゃあ足は今までに使ったことないんだから
これから使うぞと できません
それも壊れています 例えば
もうあまりにもごちそうを食べちゃって
舌を使いすぎ お腹を使いすぎ
それで味覚 味覚がなくなって
お腹が壊れちゃっても大丈夫でしょ
わかりますね 使いすぎだから
しかし 他の器官はビシビシ働いてくれますかね
働いてくれます すべては互いに協力し合って生きているんです
体の眼耳鼻舌身は互いに協力し合って生きているんです
だから一個使いすぎということは
他の部品にも悪影響を与えるんです
体の器官一つ壊れると
道連れで他の部品も壊れて廃寺になるんです
1個壊れてはいいんです
心臓が壊れたら全部壊れます
脳細胞が壊れたらともに全部壊れます
それもこの限度 学ぶ人々は
この部品の調和も学んでおかなくちゃいけないんです